do you wonder what it would be like to
compete in squid game well now you can
find out what the javascript game you
create yourself using 3js in this
tutorial shuvo teaches you how to create
a game from squigg game with the 3d
model today i have a really exciting
project for you guys we are going to
create the red light green light game
from the series squid game so if you
haven't watched that series yet the way
this game works is you have this doll
and you you'll be given a specific
amount of time and in that time you have
to move from this corner to this corner
but the catch is you can only move when
she's not looking at you if you try to
move when she looks forward you'll be
eliminated so let's see that in action
so if i refresh the game will start the
game has started and we can move we can
press arrow key to move but if we try to
move when she is looking forward as you
can see it says we lost so that's the
rule so let's try to win this game
and there we have won the game so this
is a really exciting project i hope you
are equally excited as i am so make sure
you like the video if you haven't
already yet and let's get started okay
to create this game we are going to be
using 3js 3js is a javascript 3d library
it uses webgl to render graphics on the
canvas this is really powerful and easy
to get started so if you have no
experience with 3js don't worry because
we'll be doing a lot of copy pasting
from the documentation and i'll be going
over the codes briefly okay so let me
close this window and in my file
explorer as you can see i have created a
folder called squid game chat we will be
working on this folder so let's open it
up with vs code so click on open with vs
code and now we are going to create the
index.html file so let's say index.html
and we are also going to create two
folder one is js for the javascript file
and one is css for the css file so css
like so
now in the css let's create a style.css
file so let's say style
dot css and in the javascript we need a
main.js file so new file main.js
so now let's link them in our html first
let's create the basic markup let me
close the sidebar control b to close the
sidebar now exclamation mark tab and it
will create the basic boilerplate here
let's link our style sheet so let's say
link and the hr app will be css for
slash style.css
also link our javascript so let's say
script source equals to js forward slash
main.js like so
and let me open it up with our live
server so click on open with live server
and it will be open in localhost colon
5500 okay now we want to use 3js in our
project so let's download the 3.js so go
to go to your chrome and search for 3js
github
and the first link will take you to the
github page of 3js
so from here click on the build button
and then click on the three dot main.js
so dot min basically means is the
compressed version it will load faster
now click on the raw button after that
you can click ctrl s to save it and we
want to save it in our project folder so
navigate to your project folder go to
the javascript folder and when to save
it as three dot main.js so click on save
okay now if we if we open up our sidebar
and in the javascript folder we'll see
we have the three dot main.js so let's
let's link that file so we're going to
say script source equals to js forward
slash three dot main.js like so
okay now let's go to the 3js
documentation page and here click on the
documentation
and in the documentation page you'll see
we have a lot of codes that we can copy
paste to get started so let me copy all
these codes
ctrl c
and paste it ctrl v like so let me close
the sidebar again and now if you go to
our page
you'll see we have this black canvas
so let's see what's happening so first
we're creating a new scene by saying new
three dot scene so scene is basically
what we see
to see it we need a camera so in the
second line we are creating a new camera
by saying new three dot perspective
camera so we have many types of cameras
the perspective camera is most basic so
the documentation if you search for that
here is the perspective camera as you
can see that the perspective camera
takes four argument the fob the aspect
the near and far so this will make sense
if you're into photograph graphic or
camera otherwise you can leave this
default this will work just fine then
we're creating a renderer so the
renderer is what is used to render all
the graphics in our canvas
then we are saying render dot set size
and passing window dot inner width and
inner height so basically we are saying
the renderer should be the size of our
window
and then the renderer.dom element will
give us the canvas and we are appending
that canvas to our documented body
so if we save it this we get this black
canvas and but we have this little white
space on left top and left so let's try
to remove that in the css so let's say
target everything and we're going to say
the margin should be zero and padding
should be zero so margin zero
and the padding can also be zero if we
save this as you can see now the white
space is gone okay
now let's try to add a shape in our
scene so let's see let's go back to the
documentation so if you scroll down
actually if you go back
and then scroll down as you can see we
have some more code so let me copy all
of them again
ctrl c
ctrl v so first we're creating a box
geometry so in 3d world the shapes are
basically geometric we have many types
of geometry we have box geometry we have
sphere geometry we have cylinder
geometry we have polygons etc so the box
is the basic geometry we use box
geometry to create cubes so a geometry
is made out of triangles or vertices so
we need to wrap our geometry in with a
material so there are many type of
material but for now we just want to
give it a color so we're using the mesh
basic materials which is basically just
a color so we are specifying the color
here and then we're creating the mesh by
combining the geometry and materials
here and finally we have to add that
cube to our scene so we are seeing scene
dot add cube so if you now save it and
open up the browser open up that in
browser as you can see we can see that
is because every time we add something
to our scene or update something we have
to call the renderer.render function and
we have to pass the scene and camera so
now if we save it as you can see now we
can see this see the cubes
now by saying camera.position.c equals
to 5 you are basically specifying how
far from the scene should be our camera
so if i were to make it make the number
smaller
now the camera is more near to the scene
so it appears bigger if we were to make
it bigger
now the camera is more far so this
object appears to be smaller so so so 5
is a good number so let's keep leave it
at 5. so every time we add a shape to
our scene or
update anything we have to call the
renderer.trainer function but manually
calling this can be a pain which is why
we use this code this block of code so
let me copy this and then i will explain
to you
and paste it here
so first we are creating in the animate
function in the animate function we are
calling the renderer render and we are
passing scene and camera so let me just
move it down i like it too i like to put
it in the in the very bottom but it
doesn't matter really okay so what is
happening in the request animation frame
we are passing the animate function so
what what the request animation frame
will do is call the animate function
again and again so if i were to console
log something here so if i say
console.log hello world and in the
browser if i now open the console
you'll see hello world is being printed
again and again so basically the animate
function will be called again and again
so now we don't have to manually call
this function called the render.render
function here
okay now let's look at some animations
we can animate our cube so let's try to
animate our q cube so in the animate
function we can say something like cube
dot rotation
cube dot rotation
oops cube dot rotation dot x plus equals
to 0.01 so basically you keep increasing
the rotation dot x so if we now save it
as you can see our cube is now rotating
in the x axis if we were to say rotation
dot y
it would rotate in the z axis if we were
to say rotation dot z it would rotate in
the z axis so the number basically is
specifying how fast it should rotate so
if we were to make it point five
now it rotates faster if we had to make
it even smaller
now it is rotating very very slowly okay
let me remove this code
and let me remove this actually let's
just comment it comment this out for now
so we don't want the cube
instead what i want is the doll so how
we can create that also so in the
sketchup i have found this 3d model of
the doll so this guy created it and he
is allowing us to use it for free so you
just have to create a account in
sketchup after that you can click on
download 3d model and download the gldf
version so click on download and it will
start downloading it by the way i will
leave the link to this page in the video
description and i'll also leave the link
to the finish code in the video
description so you'll be able to get
everything from there so if you decide
to follow along
and get stacked you can refer to that
quotes okay let's wait for this to
finish okay the download is now complete
so we can right click and click on show
in folder
and then i'm going to click on extract
files
and let's say the folder name should be
models
so let me rename this to models
so now this zip file has been extracted
in this models folder here we have all
the files so let me click on the cut
and let's put it in our project folder
so
so my project is in www and then inside
the squid game chart and i'm going to
paste the folder here so click on paste
and we can close the file explorer now
and close this tab and if you open up
our sidebar again you'll see we have now
had this models folder inside that we
have the files for the 3d model so now
let's see how we can use the 3d model
with 3js okay if i go to the
documentation page again and search for
gltf
here you see the glt uploader click on
this
and this again gives us some example on
how we can load a 3d model so let me
copy this
copy this line of code so ctrl c
and ctrl v so first we are creating a
new gltf loader model but to be able to
use this gld uploader we have to first
add it to our javascript so again go to
the 3js github page
and then click click on the examples
and then
and then click on javascript folder
after that go to the loaders
and here you will see the glt uploader
so click on that and again we can click
on the raw button and press ctrl s to
save it so we have to save it as
gltfloader.js so save
as you can see the gltf loader has been
added to our project so let's link it in
our javascript also so let's in our html
also so let's say script source equals
to
this time it will be js forward slash
gltfloader.js
like so
now this line here would have worked if
we were to install the glt uploader with
npm and imported it but since you are
using since we are using the regular
script file
instead of just saying glt uploader we
have to say three dot glt uploader so
simply say three dot glt uploader and
now this should work
let's see what next we have to do so
after that we have to
call the loader.load function to load
our 3d model so let's do that so we can
say loader
loader.load and here we have to
we have to specify the path to our 3d
model so our 3d model file is in the
models folder after that we have this
scene.jltf so let's say dot dot forward
slash since we are in the javascript
folder we have to go one folder up then
in the models folder that's why we're
saying dot dot forward slash models
and then we're going to say
scene.jltf
now this loader.load function will load
this gldf and once the loader is load we
will have a callback function executed
so this callback function
so let's create the body of this
function here so that this callback
function will receive the loaded gltf so
let's call it gltf
and then we can say scene.at gltf.c
and now if we save it
and go to the project as you can see we
can see nothing
let's see why is that let's open up our
console
so we don't have any error but we still
can see it that is because currently in
our scene we don't have any light we
need a light to be able to see objects
or models so let's add some light so
again let's go to the documentation and
search for light
in 3ds again we have various type of
light but the most basic light is the
ambient light so click on the ambient
light
and let's copy this code again
and let's paste it let's say let's paste
it here ctrl v so first we're creating a
new ambient light
and then here the here we're specifying
the color of our light in css you may
have said hashtag four zero four zero
four zero but in javascript we simply
say 0x and then the code so
this is the code and we can delete this
comment we don't need it so now if we
save this
and go back and as you can see we have
this doll okay so let's change the light
color to white so let's say ffff ffff
and now we can see the doll much clearer
but the doll is very big so let's scale
it down so we're gonna say c
g ltf
dot scene
dot scale so we're going to call the
scale function
and we're going to say dot scale
dot set we have to call the set function
to set the scale okay now since we are
in a 3d world we have three dimensions
and let's say we want to scale it to 0.4
on all dimensions so let's say 0.4
0.4
0.4 likes and now if we save it it
should be scale so it's that spelling is
s-c-a-l-e now if you save it
as you can see now the doll is a lot
smaller but but one problem you'll see
is if i try to resize my screen as you
can see the canvas does not reside okay
let's try to make this responsive to
make this responsible we're going to use
this block of code so let's see what's
happening so first we are saying window
dot ad event listener
we're
listening for the resize event and we're
calling this function so whenever we
resize our screen so if we resize our
screen
this function will be executed and now
let's see what we're doing in this
function so first we're saying camera
dot aspect equals to window.innerweb
divided by window.innerheight since
basically we have resized our screen now
the aspect ratio of screen has been
changed so now we are setting the aspect
ratio to the new expect to the new
aspect ratio of our screen
and now since we have changed the aspect
ratio we have to call the update
projection matrix on the camera and
finally we have to say render dot set
size and to and set the size to the new
window dot inner width and we indirect
inner height or the current we in our
width and inner height of our window so
if we now save it and now if we resize
our window as you can see now the canvas
also resizes okay
now let's bring the dollar a bit down so
we can say
gltf so let's say gltf dot scene dot
position dot set
and here we can set the position in the
x y and the z axis so we're going to set
the position in z axis so let's try one
so if we say one it goes up but we want
it to come down so instead we can use
negative one
and negative one should be good enough
now let's try to change the background
color so
to change the background color we are
going to say renderer so we can oops to
do that we can say renderer dot set
clear color so set clear color and here
we have to say specify a color so i have
already chosen a color let me use that
so the color i have chosen is b7
c
3 f 3 if we now save it as you can see
now we have this bluish color and the
second argument is basically the opacity
of the color so we want one or full
opacity okay now instead of just loading
this
loading the model like this i want to
create a new class called doll so we can
have some methods inside that class and
easily call them so let's create a class
called all so we can say class doll
inside that we're gonna have a
constructor function so we can say
constructor
and let me cut all this code
so cut
and paste it here ctrl v so if we now
save this the doll won't be visible in
the screen anymore that is because we
have to create a new dog object so let's
try to create a new dual object so let's
say
let doll
equals to new doll so now if you save it
now again we see this doll and also
where we i want to say this dot doll
it should be doll equals to gltf.c so
like so so now we can have some method
in this class so let's take let's create
a method called look back so look
back this will make the doll look at the
back side so so in this function we are
going to say doll dot rotation dot y to
some value so let's try one so now if we
were to say doll dot look back so doll
dot look back let me
call the function and save it and now if
you look at our console
you'll see we have some error that that
is saying cannot read properties of
undefined so there is two reason for
that so first reason is
it takes some time for our model to load
so let's use a set timeout so we can say
set timeout
and let's say we are going to call this
function
we are going to call the dollar so we
are going to call that doll.look back
after let's say one second so 100 1000
millisecond if we save this we'll see we
again have some error so it is saying
cannot read properties of undefined that
is because we have used the regular
function here so if you use regular
function it creates its own context so
now that now inside the function we're
saying dot this dot doll we're saying
this function dot dot so so we want this
we want this to point to the this point
to this class so we can't use a regular
function we're going to use a arrow
function
like so now if we save this after one
second as you can see that dollar
rotates so let's try
draw should rotate to let's say negative
one
and now let's try negative two
okay i think negative 3.15 will make the
doll look backward
so now as you can see if we call that
lookback function that all looks like
backward so we can also have a dot look
forward function so we can say look
forward
we can say look forward
and actually let's call it backward not
back
so the look forward function will simply
say
this dot dot dot rotation equals to zero
so now if you were to say doll dot look
forward
and call it as you can see that doll
looks forward and if you had to call
doll dot loop backward
so look backward
the doll will look at the backwards back
side but now as you can see the doll
rotates all on a sudden but we want we
want the doll to rotate slowly gradually
or animate so for that we are going to
use an animation library called gsap so
simply go to google and search for g sub
and this is the official site of g sub
so g sub is a really powerful animation
library for javascript so click on the
get started here and from here if we
scroll down as you can see this gives us
a cdn link so i'm going to copy this
link
ctrl c and paste it
ctrl v
so again click ctrl s to save it so and
to save it at gsab.main.js so save okay
now let's open up our sidebar again and
in the javascript folder as you can see
now we have this gsab.min.js so let's
add it to our html also so again we are
going to say script source equals to it
will be js forward slash
gsab.main.js like so if we now save it
let's close this tab we don't need it
anymore and let's close our sidebar by
saying control b
now in the main.js so here instead of
saying doll.rotation.y equals to three
point negative three point something let
me comment this line out and here
instead of this we are going to use the
g sub so here we are going to say g sub
dot true the object
the object we want is the digital dot
rotation and the property we want to
animate is the y so we want to animate
the rotation.y so the rotation.twice
should go from 0 to negative 3.15
in one second so that's
that's what we're doing by saying this
update so if we now save it
as you can see now now the doll animates
smoothly so let's try to say
0.45 so in 450 millisecond
now it takes 450 milliseconds for the
draw to rotate so now let's do the same
for the look forward function so ctrl c
and paste it here here we want to
animate from negative 3.15 to 0
like so so now if you open up our
console
and call the doll dot look forward
function it looks forward but it
animates forward direction if you have
to call that look backward function it
looks backward but but it's rotating
smoothly so this is much better now
okay now let's create the track that the
player have to cross so let's say let's
create a function for that so let's say
function and let's call it create track
so create
track
and create track function will create
the track to create that trap we are
going to use cube so we are going to use
like three cubes so
to create cubes we know we have to do
all these so let's create a utility
function for that so we are going to say
function
create cube so create cube
and in this function we can simply copy
this codes so ctrl x
and ctrl v
let me uncomment this
and fix the indentation like so okay now
let's try to call this createqueue
function in our create track function so
let's me
so let's call that function here like so
and let's call the create track function
now so create track
if we now call the function and save it
as you can see now we have this cube
okay let me comment out the code for the
dolls for now and now if we save it as
you can see we have this cube but we
don't want the cube to be this size we
want to specify the size so let's see
how we can do that so let's again go to
the box geometry so we can say box
geometry
so as you can see when creating the
geometry we can pass argument so we so
we can pass the width the height and the
depth of our cube so let's do that so so
in the create cube function we are gonna
receive argument call size
and when creating the box geometry we
are going to pass the size dot height
we are going to pass the size dot w for
width
size dot h for height
and size dot d for the depth
okay now where we are calling the create
cube function let's pass the size so
we're going to say the width should be
the width should be let's say 0.2 so it
will be a skinny cube and the height can
be let's say 1.5
and the depth can be one so let's say d
equals to one so now if we save this
this is how our cube looks like but now
we want one cube to be on this side and
one cube on this side so
the function will also take the position
8. so let's say position x so and inside
the function we are going to say
cube.position.x equals to position x so
now in the function
if we were to pass some position
so let's say the position
x can be let's say three
now it is in this side if we were to say
negative three
it will be on this side
okay let's create some global variables
so i'm going to create global variables
here so let's add a comment here
specifying that we are creating global
variables here so let's say global
variables
and we are going to have one global
variable for start position so here
let's say we are going to have a
variable called con start
underscore pause underscore position
and let's say the start position will be
three and the end position will be
negative three or we can say negative
start pause for negative three
like so
actually this should be in position so
let's say end underscore position
like so now where we are calling the
star create cube function we can pass
the start position and if we save it we
got a cube on the on this side and we
can also call this function again this
time we're gonna pass the
position x as in position
now we have one
now we now we have one cube here but now
the cube is kind of rotated so let's fix
that
so let's say our createqueue function
will also take a take argument called
root x for rotation x
and by default it will be 0 like so
so now inside the body we can also say
cube dot rotation dot x equals to vertex
like so
so let's try to rotate it
so let's try to rotate our cube so let's
say the first cube's rotation should be
let's try 0.4
oops
okay so looks like the cube is being
rotated in the wrong axis so let's fix
that so let's call it y
and we want to rotate it rotate the y
and we want to say rotation dot y equals
to rod y
like so so
that
so saying 0.4 is making it even worse so
let's say negative 0.4 now it's looking
much better let's try 0.3
let's try 0.35 actually
and yeah 0.35 should be good enough so
and for that
in
and for the second cube let's copy this
and this time it will be positive 0.35
like so control v and for this cube the
position x will be 0 and so it will be
in the middle so now we have this cube
here so now we have this cube in the
middle let's also say rotation should be
0
and for this one let's say the width
will be starting position
times two so if we do this
we will have a cube that spans from this
side to this side so let's give it a
different color okay so let's say our
create cube function will also take a
color as this argument so let's say
color
and the default color will be let's say
z
0 x and the hexadecimal value so the
color i want is f
fbc851
so now
here instead of saying color equals to
hashtag this color code we're gonna spa
and i'm gonna say this will be the color
that we pass in the while calling the
function so color
if i now save it as you can see now our
cube is this orange color okay the cube
is on top of other cubes so in our
creature function now we are also going
to return the created q so we are going
to say return cube
like so
okay so this is our biggest cube this
one so let me just
put it on top of other two
and now since we are returning the cube
where we can say this dot
position dot z
equals two and let's say the position
dot zero will be negative one so if we
now save it
this is how it looks okay instead of
saying point one let's try
instead of saying negative one let's try
a negative point eight
and yeah point negative point eight
works perfect and also for this one
let's change the color so let's pass a
color here so the color i have chosen is
e5 is 716.
so this is basically a darker orange
color like so so now let's uncomment the
new doll function here and it looks like
the doll is getting overlapped with the
cube so let's say so let's say the
position 0 will be negative 1 so if we
now save it
now it looks better but now we have this
gap so in so we're specifying the width
so let's also add some more value here
so let's say 0.2
so now it is spanning from starting
position to ending position like so okay
now just like the doll let's create a
class for our player which will be just
a circle so let's create a classical
player so i'm going to say class player
and in the constructor function so let's
say constructor
so for the player when to create a
sphere so let's go to the documentation
page and search for sphere
and here is a sphere geometry
so let's copy the codes ctrl c and we
can paste them here and now instead of
box geometry we are using the sphere
geometry the sphere geometry takes the
radius the height segment and width
segment and then we're creating the
sphere with the geometry and material
like so so now let's save it go to our
page
and let's try to create a player so
let's say
const player
so we are going to say cons player
if we now save it we still can see the
sphere that is because the sphere is too
big so let's so let's say the radius
should be let's try just one
so here it is our sphere this is still
too big so let's say 0.4
or let's say 0.2
or let's say 0.3
and point 3 should be good for the color
let's try the white color so let's say
ffff
so now we have this white sphere
now the position of the sphere should be
in here so let's say sphere dot position
dot x
so sphere
the position dot x equals to the start
position
like so now i want to create a function
called run and if we call the run
function the sphere should start moving
so we are going to create a function
called run
now before doing that let's just say
this dot player so this dot player
equals to sphere and we also want to
know some info about the player so we
are going to say this dot info or this
dot player info
this is what player info will be our
object so here we're again going to save
and we are going to say position x
equals to start position so basically
where the sphere is currently so
currently the sphere is here so we're
saying position dot x equals to start
position
we also want the velocity so we are
going to say velocity
and we are going to say the velocity
should be zero so velocity is basically
speed so if the velocity is zero the
sphere won't move but if the velocity is
one the sphere will move with a speed of
one so
we also want a function called update
and inside this function first we are
going to say this dot player info
dot position x
plus equals to this dot player info dot
velocity so keep increasing the player's
position x
and then we're also going to say this
dot player dot position x equals to that
this dot equals to this dot player dot
position x
and we have to keep calling the update
function so in the animate function here
we are also going to say player dot
update like so
but now the sphere is not moving so if
we were to say the velocity is point
zero one
now the sphere moves in that direction
so instead of adding let's subtract so
minus equals two
and now as you can see the sphere moves
in that direction
but initially we want the velocity to be
zero and when we call the run function
the velocity in velocity should increase
so we can say so in the run function we
can say this dot player dot velocity
equals to 0.3 0.03 like so so if we save
it
and then if open up the console
and call the player dot run so if we
were to say player dot run
as you can see the sphere is moving but
we want to call the run function when we
press our up arrow key so let's do that
so we are going to use some event
handling here so we are going to say
window dot ad event listener so we are
going to say window dot ad event
listener and we are going to listen for
the key down event
and here for now lets just say alert e
dot key like so so now if i were to
press some key it alerts the key if we
press so if i were to press the up arrow
key it says up arrow so here inside this
function we want to check if we press
the up arrow so we are going to say if e
dot
key
equal equals to
arrow up
if it is then we want to call the
player.run function so we are going to
say player.run so now if i save it and
now press press the up arrow as you can
see the player starts moving but when i
release my finger from the up arrow we
want the player to stop running so let's
create a function called stop
so here is our class so let's create a
function called stop
so in this function we are going to say
this dot player info
dot velocity
equals to zero so we are setting the
velocities to zero so there is stop
moving
so now we are also going to listen for
the key up event so
copy this and here we are listening for
the key up
so the key down is when you press down
arrow and key up is when you release
that arrow so inside here instead of
calling the run function we are going to
call the stop function like so so if we
now save it
and press our arrow key it starts moving
and if you release our arrow key it
stops moving
now to make this a little bit more
interesting what we can do is instead of
making the player stop all on a sudden
we can make it so that it takes some
time for the player to stop so we can do
g sub the two we can say this dot player
info and we want to animate the velocity
and let's say the duration to be for now
let's say one
like so
so if we press the arrow key the ball
starts moving but if we release the
arrow key the ball moves for a while and
then stop so this will make the game
even harder and more interesting but
instead of duration to be one one is too
long
let's say 0.1 so 100 milliseconds so it
will take 100 milliseconds for the
player to stop running which will make
the game a little bit more interesting
and let's delete this comment we don't
need it now i want to show a text here
so let's create a text so you can create
a text with 3js as well but i am going
to use a regular html text so i am going
to have a paragraph text with a class of
text
and here we can see for now lets just
say loading
like so
so here is our text so now you can see
the canvas is pushed down but we want
that text to be on top of the canvas so
we are going to say our text to have a
position of fix so let's say dot text
to have a position
of fixed
and let's say this should have a font
size of let's try 50 pixel
like so and let's also say the font
family
to be arial
like so let's say front weight will be
bold so font weight
bolt like so and let's center it so we
can say left to 50 percent and we're
also going to going to say transform it
was to translate x so translate x and it
will be negative 50 percent
so now if we save this as you can see
our text is in the center and you can
see our text is in the center so let's
also say the top should be 10 pixels so
let's say top
to be 10 pixel 10 pixel
like so also we want some shadows so
let's say text shadow so let's say it
takes the shadow and let's say 0 pixel
from the x axis 2 pixel from the y axis
the blur can be 5 pixel and lazy let's
use some dark colors so let's say rgb a
0 0 0 and opacity can be let's say 0.3
so now the text is a little bit more
visible ok now i want to create a method
in our
doll class so inside the doll i'm going
to create a method called start
so start
what this method will do is start the
roll so the doll will look backward for
some time then it will turn around and
look forward for some time then again do
the same so let's do that so in the
function first thing we are going to do
is say look backwards so let's say look
backward so this dot look backward and
now we want the doll to keep facing
backward for some time so we want to use
some delay here or we want the execution
to be stopped for some some time so i'm
going to create a function called delay
so function called delay
and what this function will do is take
time as its argument and then return a
promise that will resolve after the
given time so we can use this to stop
execution of our codes for for a while
so now we can make our start function
asynchronous by saying async and here we
can say avoid delay and let's say we
want to delay for one second and after
once again we want this to look forward
so we are going to say this dot look
forward and then again do a delay so
we're again going to say await delay and
let's say
1000 second also and then we're going to
call the this dot start function so this
dot start so as you can see this is a
recursive function okay so now in the
set timeout so where is the set amount
instead of saying doll dot look backward
we can say doll.start so if we had to
say doll dot start you'll see
the doll looks backward for a second
then turns around then looks forward for
a second like so
but instead of saying once again once
again we can use a random number so this
will make the game more hard and less
predictable so let's do that so let's
say
the
time should be math.random so we're
going to say math
so are going to say math.random and we
are going to say 1000 seconds this will
give us
a number between 0 to 1 000 and if we
were to add
and if we were to add 1000 to it
now we'll get and
we'll get a number between 1000 to
2000 so
the dollar will look backward for one
second to two seconds so if we now save
it
the doll looks backward for random
amount of time
we can do the same for the look forward
so let's copy this
ctrl c and paste it here
so this time let's say 750
to 700 and plus 750 so this will look
forward for 750 millisecond to 1.5
second
save
and now the doll looks at forward and
backward for a random amount of time so
this is more hard and pretty
unpredictable for the used player so now
our doll looks at forward and backward
for random one dot time and we can press
the arrow key to move our player so now
we are ready to implement the game logic
so first i am going to create a function
called init that will initialize the
game so let's create a function called
init
this will also be a asynchronous
function so async so here first what
we'll do is delay
we'll use avoid delay and we'll delay
for let's say 500 milliseconds and after
that the text should set up starting in
three after some time that it should set
starting in two starting in one and then
go so first let's target our text so our
text had a class of text so let's create
that
so let's say const
text
equals to document dot query selector
and our text had a class of text so dot
t e x takes like so now let's go to our
init function
and inside the function let's say text
dot inner text
equals to we are going to say starting
so starting in three
like so so now let's call the init
function so
in it save
and as you can see now it says starting
in threes so let me copy this three more
times
so after
500 millisecond it will say starting in
two
and after that it will say starting in
one and then it will say starting and
then it will say go so the game will
start
save it as it as you can see it says
starting in three two one go and after
that we are going to call a function
called start game so start game
and let's create that function
so function start game so inside that
function we are going to call this doll
dot start so let's
let's delete this now and we're going to
call the doll dot start here so let's
say doll dot start so now if we save it
as you can see it says loading three two
one and after that that doll starts
moving around or turning around whatever
you want to say okay now let's also show
our progress bar so the progress bar
will just be a cube so we're going to
say let progress bar
equals to we are going to again call our
q function so create cube so create cube
and for the create cube the width will
be let's say 8 the height will be let's
say one
so height equals to actually let's say
point one and the depth will be one
like so so if we save it okay we have
some error that is because we also have
to pass a position x so let's say
position x should be zero
save it okay this should be d
equals to one or depth equals to one
save it
so now we have this progress bar here
okay the weight is too much so let's say
which
which should be five
here is our progress bar we and the
progress bar to be in the top so let's
say
so we are going to say progress but
position that y equals to let's drive
3.35 if we save it
as you can see here is our progress bar
now we need to make it functional so as
time goes the width of progress bar
should decrease so let's create another
constant so let's go to our variables
here and let's create a constant so
let's say cons time limit so that this
will time limit for our game
so time underscore limit
let's say the time limit should be 10
second and now in the start function
where is the start function let's find
it out so here is our start function so
that we can again use the g sub so we
can say g sub dot 2 and we want to
animate our progress bar so let's say
progress bar
dot scale so we're going to say dot
scale
so we're going to set the scale x to 0
in the time limit or in 10 seconds so if
we now save it
as you can see the progress bar starts
shrinking down also we can specify
easing function here so we can say is
equals to none it will be linear like so
so save it
and now the progress bar moves okay one
thing you will notice is the player can
start moving even before the game is
started so like as you can see i can
move before the game has started so we
don't want that so let's create a
variable called game stat for game
status so in our variables here we're
going to say const
game stat for game status so game stat
so initially the game stat will be
loading copy this and let's go to our
event listeners here so here and inside
the if we are going to say if game stat
if game stat is not equals to start it
then we don't want to do anything so
we're simply going to say return
so now if i press the arrow key as you
can see the ball does not move so inside
the start function here the start game
we can say game stat equals to started
so game stat equals to
start it
but i just realized that since we are
reassigning to a constant will it will
give us some error so let's go back to
our variables here instead of saying
cost it will be late
like so so now once the game is started
we can press the arrow key to move like
so so now we pretty much have everything
ready to go now we just have to
implement the game logic okay so now in
the player class where is that so let's
find it here is our player layer class
we're going to create another
function called stick
this will check that if the winner has
crossed the board or if the winner has
lost so
inside the update function we can call
the check function so let's say check
this dot check and since in the
animation loop where keep calling
the update function the check function
will be also called again and again so
now what we want to do is
check if the doll is facing forward and
the velocity of our our
velocity of our player is not equals to
zero that means the player was moving
when the doll was looking forward that
means the player has lost so let's try
to do that so first we need to create a
variable
so let's create a variable called let is
looking backwards so he is looking
backward
so by default it could be true so let's
say true it should be eased looking
backward like so so once the doll looks
backward we want this to be true once
that doll looks forward we want this to
be false so let's see how we can do that
so let me copy this
inside the dual class we have this look
forward and look backward button let me
cut delete this we don't need it as you
can see it takes 450 millisecond for the
doll to look backward so we can do a set
timeout
so we can say set timeout
and we're gonna run this function after
450 milliseconds and after 450
milliseconds what we can do is say is
looking backward equals to true
and let me copy this and let's paste it
so ctrl v so here we want to say looking
backward equals to
false
okay but even if the doll rotates just a
little bit we should be able to move so
instead of saying 450 let's just say
150. so if the doll has rotated just a
little bit we are free to move like so
save now let's go to the players check
function so in the check function we are
going to say if
player so we are going to say this dot
player info
player info dot velocity so velocity
is greater than zero
and that doll is looking forward so
we're going to say if exclamation mark
is done looking backward
that means if the doll is looking
forward in that case we can say we can
for now let's just say alert you you
lost okay now let's try to play it
so as you can see when we try to move
when the doll is looking forward we lose
so it is working and in the check
function we we also want to check if the
player has successfully crossed this
line so if the player's position x is
greater than the ending position that
means the player has one so let's say if
let.position.x is less than ending
position that then we'll say you want so
let's comment this out for now and let's
try to move
and as you can see it says you win after
your position dot x is here so and
because we set the balls x to 1 the ball
have to cross a little more space for
than the starting angle so instead of
saying well same position that x is less
than this we can say position x is less
than this plus 0.4 like so and let's try
to move
so now as you can see once we cross this
line which it says you won't so now we
can uncomment this
so control for slash uncomment okay
let's try to play it
okay it looks like we have a little bit
of error let's fix that so
in this function we have messed up in
the loop backward function this should
say 150 and this one should say 450 x
instead
like so so save it let's try to play it
one more time
it says you lose
let's play one once more
and as you can see if you successfully
cross the track it says you win
now instead of alert what we want to do
is as you can see if i try to
if i say okay the alert will keep coming
that is because the check function is
being called again and again so if the
player wins and lose wins or lose what
we are going to do is say game stat
equals to over
and now let's go to the animation frame
here is our animation stream
so we are going to say
if
game state equals equals to so game stat
equal equals to over
we are going to return so we don't want
to this function to be called ever again
so like so okay so let's save it
and now let's try to run it so once you
lose it says alert zero you lose and now
you can close it and once you lose you
cannot move forward anymore okay now
let's make the test text say you win if
you win and say lose if you lose so
let's do that
so let's go to our check function
here we are going to say text dot inner
text equals to so text dot inner text
equals to you lose and here we can say
text dot inner text equals to you win so
let's try to run it
okay let's delete the alerts we don't
need the alerts anymore
so as you can see if we try to move it
says you lose so let's try to win now
and now it says you won't
another thing we have to tackle is but
if the player runs out of time
if he runs out of time we want to say
time over so let's do that
so inside the start function so let's go
to the start function
here we're also going to do a set
timeout so we're going to say set
timeout
like so and we're going to time
run the function after that time limit
is over so i need to say time limit
times 1 000 that is because our time
limit is 10 which is in second but the
set timeout takes time in millisecond
that is why we we are multiplying it
with 100 so after that we are going to
say we are going to say if the game stat
is not equals to over
that means that the player have run out
of time but he couldn't clear this track
so we are going to say text dot inner
text equals to let's say you run you ran
out of time so you
you ran
out of time
okay now let's see what happens if we
run out of time
as you can see it says you ran out of
time and we cannot move anymore we can
do anything but if we refresh we can
play again so let's try to play
oops we lost let's try to play one more
time
we have lost again let's try one more
time this time i'm gonna win
oh no i have lost again let's try one
one last time
and there we have won the game so now
everything is working
as intended so now we have successfully
created the red light green light game
from squid game i hope you enjoyed this
video and you have created it yourself
as well don't forget to like and
subscribe and i will see you next time